yeah cuz my room here miss to ask if you
like do those sock puppets a guy's just
this terrible idea so this one was been
under a lot of controversy because you
know Mel Gibson and his personal life
and all that stuff never one was like
what is with this plot it's insane
mainly it was a lot of speculation over
Mel Gibson and his personal life
basically which I don't really agree
with because you got to separate the art
from the artist here's how I view it if
cameras followed all of us around and
people recorded our telephone
conversations and we were photographed
doing every little thing that we always
do we will all look pretty stupid I mean
honestly if you really think about it
and so I don't really like to judge
people that's just not my place
this film Mel Gibson plays a man who's
very depressed very down on his life
Jodie Foster plays his wife who's asked
him to leave Anton Yelchin plays his son
the Jennifer Lawrence plays a friend
Anton Yelchin has at school he's just
done he's just so down and out and one
night the dumpster he finds a soul
puppet of a beaver he puts it on and he
starts to decided you know what I'm not
gonna talk anymore I'm gonna talk as
this character he creates a character
with this thing and starts to talk to
people with it he's trying to use that
thing as some sort of a therapy to help
him get over his depression but really
what it is is he's just afraid to
confront his problems himself at first
it's very comical you know it's really
funny to see him go through things and
obviously the see people's reactions to
him just walk around oh I got the baby
bug and then it gets really a heartfelt
there's a really sweet relationship that
I really liked
between Anton Yelchin character and
Jennifer Lawrence's character there's
just a lot of good drama in this movie
and I really really enjoyed it you got
Mel Gibson with a beaver puppet on his
hand talking to people you're supposed
to really try to feel for this character
and
hard but it works Johnny foster actually
directed this movie and she did an
excellent job there now I've seen one of
her previous two efforts a little man
Tate which is about a little kid just
accept my smart and that was a good film
but nothing terribly remarkable
I did not see home for the holidays I
hear it's not very good she's clearly
good with the actors that's true because
when you have an actor who becomes a
director they know what an actor wants
from a director she gets great
performances firmer actors Mel Gibson
man he's a good actor he's a very good
in this film he has a very convincing
imitation of Ray Winstone as the beaver
I'm not sure about to me was going for
but he did work with him an edge of
darkness he sounds just like Ray
Winstone as the beaver but anyway isn't
you know experimental and weird like a
lot of actors who turned into directors
it's just it's all very well done the
hardest thing really with this movie is
that you really have to suspend
disbelief what I love about this movie
is it's different its original I'm so
tired of Hollywood just shelling out the
same movies today everything is a
prequel a sequel a remake or reboot it's
nice to see something different
something new this is a heartfelt moving
it's funny it has a lot of humor to it
but it's also very touching Jodie Foster
is very good in the movie as well Anton
Yelchin Jennifer Lawrence are great good
performances good Direction good writing
this is just a very different movie that
I really appreciated for the for that I
liked the uniqueness so I'm gonna give
the beaver three and a half out of four
stars Mel Gibson's excellent in it yeah
if it comes to your city I definitely
give it a chance